over the years sunspot has been a new
mutant an x-man
a member of x-force and an avenger but
what's the whole story behind this
particularly talented mutant
this is the untold truth of sunspot
roberto da costa's powers manifest early
in the new mutants original graphic
novel
during a high school soccer championship
game in rio de janeiro
after tackling a player who had fouled
him roberto is pinned to the ground
as the other player beats him roberto's
body turns cold black
energy emanates from him and he hurls
his attacker far away
unsurprisingly the crowd is terrified at
his appearance
and almost everyone runs away the only
one who helps roberto
is his girlfriend juliana this incident
is monitored by donald pearce a rogue
member of the nefarious hellfire club
who wants to eradicate all mutants
pierce has his goons kidnap juliana in
order to lure roberto to him
the plan works but at first it looks
like roberto will be able to overpower
the hellfire goons all on his own
his powers waned as the solar energy
drains from him however
and roberto is only saved by the arrival
of the other new mutants
unfortunately juliana doesn't survive
the ordeal
she dies jumping in front of a bullet to
meant for roberto
at the end of the new mutants roberto
returns with professor x and his other
recruits
and agrees to become a member of the
junior x-men team
he was there when the team got its own
ongoing series and remained one of the
team's mainstays throughout their run
sunspot and sam guthrie also known as
cannonball
aren't particularly friendly when they
first meet in the new mutants the
villain donald pierce
fools cannonball into working for him
and he helps attack roberto and his
friends
by the end of the story however sam has
seen the light
when sam shows up at xavier's school
toward the end of the new mutants
roberto was initially the only one
unwilling to accept him
but his new friends convince him to give
sam a second chance
but roberto and sam's friendship is
forged early in the new mutants ongoing
series
helped in no small part by the fact that
of all the founding members
they're the only two boys their
friendship faces some difficult tests
however
such as when roberto unintentionally
hurts sam in 1987's
fallen angels number one and later when
the two feud over the affections of
fellow x-force member
meltdown nonetheless their friendship
remains strong
so much so in fact that in the new
mutants revival that launched in late
2019
it's sunspot who insists that the team's
very first adventure
be to blast into space so they can find
cannonball and bring him back to the new
mutant homeland
of krakowa in the late 80s sunspot
briefly left the new mutants for a very
different kind of team
in 1987's fallen angels number one
roberto accidentally hurts sam during a
friendly soccer game
his teammates are pretty vocal in
letting him know how unhappy they are
about this
and shortly afterward roberto happens
upon a document professor x wrote about
him
expressing concern he might someday go
down darker paths
ashamed roberto leaves behind an
apologetic
note and leaves the mansion the new team
sunspot eventually joins is about as
ragtag as you get
along with other mutants such as boom
boom mad rocks the multiple man
warlock and siren this group would
eventually include
moon boy devil dinosaur the cyborg gomi
and even gomes two cyborg lobsters and
fallen angels number eight however
sunspot and warlock leave in order to
return to the new mutants
as part of 2019's dawn of x event a new
fallen angels title was released for the
first time in 30
years though it's much more serious in
tone and has little to do
with the original series beyond the name
sunspot has nothing to do with this new
team
which is initially comprised only of
psylocke x23 and cable
definitely no lobsters this time
sunspot's powers originally seem
limited to physical strength and
durability but that changes around the
time he joins
x-force in 1992's x-force number 15
the team rescues sunspot from the
villain gideon who had kidnapped the
hero and subjected him to
experiments that increase his powers
sunspot joins the ranks of x-force and
learns he now has the power to release
concussive blasts from his body
no longer limited to solar power sunspot
can absorb
all kinds of energy including heat and
even radiation
[Music]
in 1993's x-force number 28 in a moment
of desperation
sunspot also learns he can fly it isn't
clear if the villain gideon's
experiments added powers
sunspot wouldn't otherwise have access
to or if they allowed him to discover
abilities he always had the potential to
use
regardless the comics haven't always
been consistent in terms of his newer
powers
in some instances after long absences
sunspot shows up with his expanded
powers having disappeared or reappeared
without much of an explanation when
sunspot's powers first manifest in the
new mutants
the only person who helps him is his
girlfriend juliana
and we all know what happened to her
years later however
the hellfire club figures out a way to
use juliana against roberto
forcing him into their ranks in 2000's
x-force number 98
the hellfire club makes roberto an offer
he can't refuse
aided by the demonic villain blackheart
the club raises juliana's soul from the
lands of the dead
in return for joining the hellfire club
as its black rook
sunspot is promised juliana will be
resurrected in the body of another woman
feeling obligated due to juliana's own
sacrifice to save him
roberto agrees he eventually moves up
the ranks
becoming the lord imperial of the
hellfire club after sebastian shaw is
badly injured
in 2005's uncanny x-men number 454
later sunspot leaves the hellfire club
and returns to help teach a new crop of
mutants
in the 2008-09 series young x-men
[Music]
avengers
assemble the avengers don't tend to
include many mutants in their ranks
though they have included a few over the
years most of the mutants who have
become avengers were either
avengers before they ever joined nex
teams or were characters with long and
distinguished careers with the x-men
but it wasn't until 2012's avengers
number 2
that any of the former new mutants
joined the ranks of earth's
mightiest heroes and one of them was
sunspot
in the 2012 avengers relaunch a whole
host of new members were invited to the
team
including sunspot and cannonball in
avengers number two
the two best friends were hanging out on
a beach when sam gets a call from
wolverine and captain america
the latter of whom invites the pair into
the fold assuming that they're being
invited back into active x-men service
roberto refuses once sam tells him it's
not the x-men but the avengers they're
being invited to
however roberto instantly agrees the
pair joined the new team in the
following issue for a rescue mission to
mars
where most of the core team of avengers
are being held hostage
and soon enough sunspot has become not
just a key member of the avengers
but one of its leaders after conflict
breaks out between the earth's mightiest
heroes and the secretive group known as
the illuminati
sunspot leaves the avengers but in 2015
the marvel universe finds itself heading
towards destruction
due in part to a growing number of
so-called incursions
in which alternate earths are colliding
and being destroyed
not willing to be a part of the war
between the avengers and the illuminati
but also unable to stand on the
sidelines roberto uses his family's
wealth to buy advanced idea mechanics
aim has been a villainous presence in
the marvel universe for decades
and roberto has some serious
housekeeping to do when he takes over
the organization
soon most of the worst elements in aim
are gone and the group is renamed
avengers idea mechanics
sunspot then uses the vast scientific
resources of the once evil group to
research
and stop the incursions to this end he
forms his own team of avengers
including other heroes who aren't
interested in the conflict between the
avengers and the illuminati
unfortunately despite everyone's best
efforts the end of the war comes with
the 2015-16 event
secret wars in which the marvel universe
is reduced to a single world ruled by dr
doom eventually however the multiverse
is restored
and in the post-secret wars marvel era
sunspot steps up to lead another team of
avengers
not long after the events of secret wars
sunspot leads a new team of heroes
though he doesn't use the name sunspot
during this period
roberto's aim is absorbed by shield
becoming its intelligence division
at the same time roberto forms the u.s
avengers
including new versions of red hulk and
iron patriot
his best friend cannonball and the
cybernetic hero enigma
roberto acts mostly as the leader of the
team and rarely goes into the field
himself
he also takes on the alias citizen v a
superhero name reaching back to the
golden age of comics when marvel was
still called
timely the name originally belonged to a
world war
ii superhero but became more well-known
when the villain baron
zemo took it to disguise himself as a
hero in the 90s series
thunderbolts despite a huge promotional
push
including a first issue with over 50
variant covers
u.s avengers would only last 12 issues
as the team was dissolved after the
events of the
17 story avengers no surrender
in the 2019 line-wide marvel comics
event war of the realms
the dark elf malekith leads his armies
to earth
to bring the final of the ten realms
under his rule
avengers and street level heroes alike
rise up to protect the earth against
hordes of dark elves
trolls frost giants and more and they
aren't alone
in the mini-series war of the realms
uncanny x-men
mutant heroes lead civilian survivors to
a baseball stadium in queens
unfortunately sunspot doesn't survive
the final battle
the villain's sabertooth allies himself
with malakith's armies and captures the
mutant magic early in the miniseries
saddling her with a mystical gem that
stops her from using her powers
in the third and final issue of the
mini-series as sabretooth and his forces
overwhelm the stadium's defenders
sunspot grabs the magic gem and absorbs
its energy
hoping the act will allow magic to use
her powers roberto's powers work on the
gem
but the hero's body explodes just
moments later
soon after sabretooth pays for his
treachery
magic decapitates the villain and
perhaps worried about his healing factor
teleports his head to parts unknown a
long list of mutants die in marvel's
2019 line of comics
wolfe spain is beaten to death banshee
is crushed havoc explodes
vanisher melts chamber is stabbed from
behind and of course
sunspot gives his life to restore
magic's powers but thanks to the 2019-20
event
dawn of x death means a lot less than it
used to for marvel's mutants
in donovak's the mutants of earth found
a new nation on the sentient mutant
island of krakowa
one of the advances possible on krakowa
is the resurrection of dead mutants
through the efforts of a group known as
the five any mutant can be brought back
from
death provided they have access to that
mutant's dna
so in 2019's new mutants revival
roberto is there to team up with his old
friends along with other recently
deceased heroes such as
wolfsbane and chamber and sure enough
sunspot demands that the new team's
first mission be to blast off into the
void
to bring his best buddy cannonball back
to earth and rejoin their new mutant
utopia
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one